other parts of the world are also easing
restrictions in spite of concerns about
moving too fast Holly Williams is in
Istanbul Turkey where stores and other
businesses have just reopened barber
shops in Turkey were forced to close
their doors for over seven weeks and
staff members like Molly Yilmaz had
their salaries trimmed today he welcomed
back his customers some are little
hairier than usual I am so happy today
France will also gradually begin ending
its nearly two months long lockdown with
many shops back in business and citizens
able to go outside without filling out a
form meanwhile in some parts of Spain
outdoor restaurants and bars will start
serving customers today no this is not
the time simply to end the lockdown this
week but in the UK with the highest
death toll in Europe over 30,000 lives
and a prime minister who himself caught
the virus things will take much longer
construction and manufacturing workers
can now go back to their jobs but
schools and the hospitality industry
will have to wait until this summer we
must have a world-beating system the
testing potential victims and for
tracing their contacts so that all told
we are testing literally hundreds of
thousands of people every day but even
in Germany a country praised for
carrying out mass testing the infection
rate has recently gone up though
scientists say they don't know how
significant that is for CBS this morning
Holly Williams Istanbul